new housing developments new companies
moving in and expanding we all know
henderson is growing fast it sure is in
fact it's the second largest city in
nevada lots of business popping up and
there are plans for more bianca hallman
live at one of the latest developments
near green valley bialca good morning
yes well here are out at green valley
you can see construction continues here
at dollar loan center arena
this will be the home for the henderson
silver nights and community events
helping to bring more dollars into this
area but this isn't the only area of
change scott mule ralph of the chamber
says industrial parks in west henderson
are expanding due to companies coming
from california the lifeguard arena
that's brought a lot of revitalization
to water street which benefits many mom
and pop businesses in the area and
there's a lot of development planned for
2022 it'll have a ripple effect
throughout the entire community
whether it's hotel rooms being filled
for the big west basketball tournament
in march or uh people going out to
dinner at the district after catching a
game at
the dollar loan center so um it all
works together in that sense and so
we're really excited about
the opening of that venue for the
community
and healthcare that's another space of
advancement in henderson in the past
year there was a new tower built at
henderson hospital and there's going to
be a new medical campus in west
henderson so that definitely is
something that our community needs more
doctors more specialists to help our
growing community and coming up in the
next half hour we're going to talk about
details regarding a grant for new
business owners so be sure to stick
around for that information reporting
live bianca holman live local now